carol higgins clark sa fille change pas
la gueule comme la maman c'est celle du
milieu la maman algues étaient coupables
d'actes non est-ce que tu connais non
mais je dois voir une fille chouih
jeunes filles le tennis
j'écris on vous appelle bloody mary où
la reine du suspense
vos romans sont publiés dans le monde
entier sont des best-sellers
internationaux
vous avez vendu pratiquement 300
millions d'exemplaires parce qu'on soit
dans pas mal de gens ici
millions d'exemplaires et rien qu'en
france des 20 ans du 25 millions
extraordinaire et vous carole vous
marcher sur les traces de votre maman
puisque chacun de vos livres se vendent
désormais à plus de 500000 exemplaires
vous la rattrape très bientôt
c'est mathématique en tous les cas merci
d'être là toutes les deux
vous faites votre tournée je viens je
vais te plait je viens pitcho vous fait
des tournées promotionnelles ensemble
vous avez partout dans tous les pays
toutes les deux vas-y toi d'abord
vraiment sorti toutes les deux un livre
donc une sorte de voyage ensemble c'est
sympa de dans quel hôtel à paris
et moi je me souviens plus en 109 4
centres de secours et you like they call
mai
d
vous rester longtemps à paris à leurs
blindés vas-y un chien oui semaine
depuis votre dernière voyage en france
est ce que vous sentez une différence
d'attitude des français par rapport aux
américains suite aux différents qui nous
a opposés sur la guerre d'irak
je dirais que les français ont toujours
été gentil avec nous et ça continue ce
sont mes amis
laquelle des deux est la plus proche
intellectuellement évidemment de george
w.bush salariaux des connaissances
connaissons les bouches ce sont des amis
je les respecte les décisions qu'elle a
prises
ça correspondait à ce qu'il me semblait
bon ce n'est pas parce qu'il voulait
quelque chose vraiment je pense penser
qu'il est sincère absolument c'est
d'équilibré psychologique mois
d'habitude je suis ravi de pouvoir le
défendre
d'accord avec sa décision mais vous la
comprenez bien alors il ya un truc que
j'ai c'est dur d'arrêter de boire
j'étais une vraie décision bravo il
n'est pas plus la réalité de voix il est
tombé dans la bible avait en fait
détourné ensemble vous avez chacune
votre livre vous mary higgins clark
votre livre s'appelle une seconde chance
et c'est publié comme d'habitude chez
albin michel
[Musique]
ça vient
on est dit ah vous remercie alors carole
vous votre livre s'appelle peu de veine
et c'est également chez albin michel
[Musique]
alors marie une seconde chance donc
cette histoire de nicolas spencer qui
est directeur d'un laboratoire
pharmaceutique qui disparaît
mystérieusement dans un accident d'avion
au moment où le vaccin anticancéreux sur
lequel il travaille
enfin son labo travail est refusée sur
le marché par les autorités en fait moi
j'avais lu toutes les histoires
d'affairisme notamment concernant un
médicament contre le cancer est en fait
je me suis posé des questions à ce sujet
c'est comme ça que j'ai eu l'idée de ce
riz livre un fana de chercheurs
disparaît refuse d'autoriser la mise sur
le marché de ce médicament est une
journaliste fait donc l'enquète et puis
elle écrit un article c'est de découvrir
la vérité est ensuite bien vous vous
payez puis vous achetez le livre sort et
la france que ce qu'est ce qui vous
donne des idées de livres comme ça est
ce que par exemple vous seriez capable
d'imaginer un livre qui débute comme ça
sur un plateau télévision avec un grand
acteur français avec une une chanteuse à
la mode oui bien sûr merci a pas
d'autres ces éléments-là l'invité irait
dans la loge pendant quelques minutes
simplement et on se dira m et où est
l'invité revenez nous vite et vous la
paix de laurier et puis quelqu'un irait
chercher l'invité serment voiture à des
peines quelqu'un essaierait de la porte
aux vraies personnes ne reprendrait
alors on essaierait de dire la porte
mais la porte sera compensée bloquer le
plan humain vous voyez agneaux entre à
profit
et puis là vous êtes bloqués
d'avoir envers qui vous étiez mais chaud
vous avez déjà lu des livres de mary
higgins clark
ça fait très très peur des gens calais
une bibliothèque avec ça alors vous
karol beck livre s'appelle pas de veine
donc c'est une nouvelle enquête de
reagan really puisque vous à la
différence de votre mère vous avez un
personnage récurrent où il ya tout à
fait mais moins connus soit va quand
même non or noir parfaite li fine nice
auquel tu parles lui enfin et surtout
elle rodez par carole était votre
assistante éditorialistes votre
documentaliste elle a tout appris en
fait à travailler en paix c'est sa
parole me voyais à la table de la
cuisine je tapais mes livres ma machine
à écrire et puis ensuite je mettais la
machine à écrire par terre et puis je
prépare le dîner
et puis l asaph après y être soustrait
puis ensuite elle a commencé à relire
mes livres lorsqu'elle était à
l'université me reprenait elle avait
raison alors vous avez un truc quand
même vous d'abord vous choisissez
toujours des sujets qui touchent les
femmes 1 c'est à dire la beauté la
fertilité
ces démarcheurs les enfants dont c'est
vrai c'est vrai vous avez toujours des
sujets qui touchent les femmes et
ensuite vous intercalé toujours une
histoire d'amour dans les logiciels juin
toujours c'est ainsi
sur la gâteau net arqua l'histoire
policière avec le dit - marie qu'est ce
que vous faites de votre pognon sans
déconner ce que je fais dans l'argent et
bien ça y est ça je mets de l'argent de
côté j'en donne enfin un petit peu comme
tous les drogues
bon alors mais mentir vous êtes née
marie en 1929 dans le bronx à new york
famille d'origine irlandaise
vous dites derrière les irlandais sont
des conteurs n'est alors votre père
avait un bar et tenait un bar mais il
est mort quand on vous aviez dix ans et
votre mère se retrouve avec trois
enfants
et puis il ne sommes pas énorme de 14
mille francs devant elle est obligée de
louer louer les chambres delà de la
maison pour survivre et vous commencé à
écrire dès l'âge de 7 ans
et puis quand vous quittez le lycée vous
prenez des cours de secrétariat
voilà donc ces sites une enfance assez
assez difficile vous faites de nombreux
boulot qui vous seront utiles plus tard
d'ailleurs parce qu'à un moment vous
êtes opératrice téléphonistes dans un
hôtel que vous entendez toutes les
conversations
j'adorerais cela jamais quand j'avais 15
ans j'avais toujours l'air plus âgées
que mon nom
son prénom son nom à y enrichir cette
nouvelle phase franchement alors après
vous avez été hôtesse de l'air hôtesse
de l'air sur la pana mais à l'époque
c'était classe 1 d'être hôtesse de l'air
c'est à dire que y'a pas un vol par
semaine par une new york c'était
l'époque des décos mais des super
constellation
c'est vrai vous souvenez ce à quoi ça
allait bien sûr que je me souviens savez
cet avion à hélice ou avec 60 personnes
à bord et puis on leur donnait le
chewing gum pour qui le supportent vous
savez des changements de pression
alors après ces petits boulots vous
marier sous l'oeil amusé de votre époux
vous commencez écrire des petites
nouvelles sur la table de votre cuisine
donc nombreux refus au départ c'est très
difficile de faire publier vos écrits
jusqu'à 1956 ou un magazine qui
s'appelle extentions magazine achète
votre première nouvelle pour 100 dollars
c'était le le début donc de votre succès
il en compte votre mari meurt on vous
retrouvez avec avec cinq enfants
monsieur clark est mort avec cinq
enfants
et là vous décidez de suivre un très bon
préceptes en fait qui est valable pour
tous les arts c'est écrit ce que tu
aurais envie de lire et à partir de là
voilà ça a commencé à marcher et vous
avez vendu 300 millions d'exemplaires ce
que tu me colossal vous travaillez
beaucoup par jour
combien de temps à peu près temps idéal
cinq heures par jour et bien sûr lorsque
je fais une campagne de promotion je ne
travaille pas et puis ensuite il va il
faut que je rattrape tout ce temps je
pense que c'est pareil pour carole c'est
la même chose
cette chance après l'émission entre vous
avez travaillé non non non je vais boire
chaque fois que je vais
dormir et puis rêvez vous êtes
excellence à comment vous appelez la
traductrice tess minh tu as mine mais
vous êtes excellente terminée vous aimez
les livres de mary higgins clark
oui bien sûr ça vous plaît j'ai un peu
peur ouais ça fait peur c'est que même
elle a peur dire que certaines fois est
en train d'écrire comme ça pendant la
nuit
et puis une fois c'est vrai il ya le feu
qui s'est rallumée dans la cheminée
green world at war s'est voilé ds et wii
est ce qui s'est passé lorsque l'on
écrit ce type de livre et puis que vous
êtes tout seul la nuit vraiment dans
votre livre et puis qu'il ya un bruit
vous savez les des maisons font des
bruits et bien on saute tout de suite à
ce moment là tu as quel âge tu as mis 26
ans mais comment les équipements
vous faites quoi cet été ce mines
portant vacances va la voir avant avant
de l'inviter pêche au thon pendant deux
mois voire avant j'espère que vous
l'avez 19 h
oui j'ai rencontré total à 1 et
sympathique oui elle va s qu'elle
traduit bien testing
oui c'est extraordinaire très bien
et voilà
marie et caroline
messieurs c'est chalon
l comme d'habitude et ce sont les
baisses rvt pour les plages elles les
femmes et de plats
[Musique]
bon alors mari car les gyms large je
vais vous laisser aller vous bougez vous
allez vous allez directement aux lilas
maintenant non room service quand même
une quinzaine à s'il vous plaît que je
vais boire un petit verre de bon vin
français
les orgies été tués excellent terrain ça
sent partout est ce que vous connaissez
le matisse bajaur vous partez avec ces
demoiselles ont même évoqué peut-être je
prendrais de l'avion ou de vittel et
passer une bonne soirée avec lui oui
vous allez vous avez vous à moi
america
merci jean les corrections de ne rien
rater de 1h10 tube abonnez vous il
mettait un coup double